it's a Monday which means even more
sexual harassment scandals Plus
president Trump enters upon a category-5
tweet storm and we'll talk a little
Federalist Papers - I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show it's
Thanksgiving week yeah we made it we're
almost there guys we're almost to the
end of the year Thanksgiving is coming
up of course on Thursday and I know
we're doing a video here about things
that I'm thankful for yes I your humble
host I'm actually thankful for some
things unbelievably enough we'll tell
you about that a little bit later this
week but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at texture so
particularly in this day and age
magazines are actually vital reading if
you were looking at The New Yorker this
this last couple of weeks it was the New
Yorker that exposed the Harvey Weinstein
scandals run in Pharos terrific work
over there that did that Vanity Fair has
been doing some very good reporting
there's some very good reporting in the
in the recent past from the Atlantic all
these magazines are very expensive you
get them on your own but if you get the
texture app then you can read all the
articles from all these magazines for
$9.99 a month they deliver unlimited
access to over 200 premium magazines and
right now you can try texture for free
and the texture app is available on your
phone it's available on your iPad again
you can call you can try it right now
for free
start your texture free trial go to
texture comm slash Ben and then if you
choose to continue my podcast listeners
will get texture for just $9.99 a month
that's 30% off they're listed price so
30% off the list price that only applies
if you are a Shapiro show listener and
use texture comm slash Ben
there are also great gift options
available for the holiday season so it
makes a terrific Christmas gift as well
textures complex gonna start your free
trial today
again magazines are doing a lot of the
best investigative journalism in the
business I'm have to subscribe to a
bunch of them separately or at least I
did until I started using the texture
app that I can actually do my own job
when you're an addict for information
texture comm is the place to go to
texture comm slash Ben download the app
and make sure that you can read all the
material you want to read texture comm
slash Ben you get a free trial and then
if you continue you got 30% off that
listed price in $9.99 a month for two
hundred magazines which is pretty
amazing plus their back issues so really
great stuff okay so it'll begin today
with the with some breaking news this
from the New York Times so the New York
Times is now suspended
famed reporter Glen thrush over
allegations of
sexual harassment so what makes this
sort of interesting is that thrush is
one of these guys who's been virtually
signaling about sexual harassment for
quite a while and he posted a facebook
note just a couple of weeks ago blasting
political journalist Mark Halperin over
allegations of sexual misconduct against
young female journalists he stated quote
young people who come into a newsroom
deserve to be taught our trade given our
support and enlisted in our calling not
betrayed by little men who believe they
are bigger than the mission only one
problem it turns out that the married
thrush apparently has a bad habit of
getting sloshed with younger female
journalists and then coming on to them
in one instance a 20-something young
reporter was so upset by such an alleged
incident that she told her friend who
texted with Rush vas reports quote three
young women I interviewed including the
young woman who met thrush in June
describes me a range of similar
experiences from unwanted groping and
kissing to wet kisses out of nowhere too
hazy sexual encounters that played out
under the influence of alcohol each
woman described feeling differently
about these experiences scared violated
ashamed weirded out I was an M angry
details of their story suggests a
pattern all of the women were in their
20s at the time their relatively early
in their careers compared to thrush
who was the kind of seasoned journalist
would be good to know at an event with
alcohol he made advances afterward they
as I did that the columnist here is
actually one of the people thrush came
onto thought it best to stand to terms
with Rush whatever their feelings so
there's a lot of this going around in
Hollywood in journalism in politics
where something bad happens and women
don't say anything because they're
afraid it's gonna ruin their career
they're afraid there's gonna be blowback
from inside the establishment and that's
not a irrelevant fear it's happened to a
lot of women in Hollywood it's happened
to a lot of women in journalism the
woman in the story the writer of the
story woman Laura McGann just five years
ago thrush quote slid into my side of
the booth blocking me in I was wearing a
skirt and he put his hand on my thigh he
started kissing me I pulled myself
together and got out of there shoving
him on my way out and apparently thrush
then told the entire newsroom that
McGann had come on to him not the other
way around McGann told her seniors at
Politico who apparently did nothing
thrush now says he doesn't drink anymore
and that he has quote done things I am
ashamed of actions I have brought great
hurt to my friends and family I'm
working hard to repair the damage that
I've done the New York Times has
suspended thrush pending an
investigation there are a bunch of
things that need to be asked here that I
think worth while asking the first
question that's worthwhile asking is the
entire journalistic community that's
coming down on politicians in Hollywood
how many of them are Gil
of the same sort of conduct it now seems
that this sort of conduct is common
across the board particularly in
high-profile industries I'm not sure
that it's happening as much in sort of
typical business in typical business
areas because you can switch businesses
relatively quickly but if you're in a
specialized industry like the journalism
or Hollywood where Fame matters then I
feel like the the rates of this are much
higher which creates this sense of
hypocrisy all these people who claim to
be feminists who are going out there and
sexually harassing or abusing the people
who are who are trying to make their way
in the world Halperin is is the first
one obviously from Politico and now you
see Glenn thrush
he was working over at Politico now at
the New York Times pretty astonishing
stuff the other thing that happens is
you see some of these accounts but it's
hard to put your finger on where exactly
can you say the sin has now taken place
the reason being that it seems like a
bit of a moving target so in thrush a
situation there a bunch of stories in
this box in this box piece in which
thrush would get drunk with a female
colleague and then he would go in for a
kiss or he'd kiss her and then she would
get up tight and walk away is that full
on sexual assault is that like Al
Franken grabbing a woman's breasts while
she's sleeping is that the equivalent of
Roy Moore going after a 14 year old like
there seemed to be gradations here that
everybody is ignoring in the in the rush
to throw everyone out now I'm ok with
throwing everyone out so long as we have
a consistent standard for how we apply
this one of the ways that you could tell
that Glen thrush was a creep and that
you could say if these stories are
correct one of the ways that in the old
flurb traditionalist morality that we
could easily say Glenn thrushes a creep
is Glen thrush is married and Glen
thrush is trying to make out with women
not his wife right that would be the
hard line in 1945 the married guy tried
to make out with a woman who is not his
wife we would all go that guy's gross
but now thanks to the sexual revolution
we're supposed to assume that that's
totally fine unless she doesn't consent
but consent is a murky area in the sense
that sometimes I mean there's one case
where the woman says she went back to
her hotel with Glen thrush they were
both drunk she was partially unclothed
she decided she'd want to go any further
and he left and then she says I don't
feel like I was sexually exploited or
abused but there she is in the story
anyway so is that a situation of sexual
abuse or exploitation is the power
dynamic that makes it bad because we
were told back in 1998
nothing to the power dynamic stuff when
Bill Clinton was shtupping his secretary
so what exactly is the thing that makes
it bad so it used to be there are some
pretty bright lines as to what made
things bad the brightest line of course
was don't have sex until you're married
right that was the brightest line it was
now some people didn't a lot of people
didn't keep that line but I'll tell you
what they did keep was getting married
after they got pregnant so it is some
fascinating sort of historical
statistics even colonial era America I
think it was something like one-third of
all babies born in colonial era America
were born before nine months - a married
couple meaning that somebody got knocked
up and then they got married but because
marriage was the standard this meant
that we at least had some area where if
you walk past this line we know that you
just did something wrong some objective
view right something that doesn't rely
on the subjective sense of what the
people involved are saying now there are
certain cases that clearly don't write
clearly rape does not involve a gray a
gray area right there's no gray area
with regard to rape certainly you know a
guy walk up to a girl and just ramming
his tongue down her throat that's
obviously sexual assault and that does
not apply a gray area but where two
people are drunken they start making out
and then the girl says no and the guy
walks away you know this is where you
get into dicey territory particularly in
title nine cases on campus where a guy
and a girl get drunk they've been told
that they can be a sexually libidinous
as they want to be and then they go to
bed together and then three days later
the girl says that she was sexually
exploited or raped what we need are some
objective measures this is not to say
the girl wasn't sexually exploited right
maybe she was but we need some sort of
objective measures that we as a society
can take a look at and say this is
really bad behavior in this case one of
the things that makes it relatively easy
is that we are still using we don't want
to admit it to ourselves but we are
still using the old concepts right in
our sexually in our sexually permissive
society we like to pretend that we're
not using old concepts here but the fact
is if Glenn thrush for a single man who
are the same age as the women he was
drinking with he'd be being treated very
differently than a 50 year old guy who's
going after 20-somethings while he's
married we're still using traditional
sexual concepts even when we don't want
to admit it that's one of the things
that's so funny about so much of leftist
perspective on these sorts of issues is
that they attempt to break with
traditional concepts of sexual mores
they try to say that those things are
hackneyed and stupid and we need to
leave those behind they trying to say
that Mike Pence is a crazy man for not
wanting to dine alone women with women
not his wife how could he it's terrible
and awful and yet as soon as somebody
does
something like this we immediately
revert back to traditional sexual mores
right there using my standard now right
this is more my standard I look at Glen
thrush and I say this is gross how dare
he that's my standard okay I mean I was
famous until I was 24 years old for as
the virgin been right because I used to
advocate publicly and still do for
virginity until marriage their holding
by my standard now the left is now
holding by my standard that a man should
not touch a woman unless they are unless
they're married essentially that a man
should not touch a woman unless he has
explicit permission from the woman that
drunken revelry 'he's that go wrong
right are a bad thing
now the left comes at it from the from
the angle of radical subjectivity and
this is where you get into dicey
territory because when I say radical
subjectivity I mean that the situation
can be exactly the same way as in
exactly the same and if the woman
perceives it differently than the man
and it's reasonable to perceive it
either way we have to take the woman's
word for her perception that's dangerous
territory because what is the man
supposed to expect so what we decided to
do instead is become puritanical about
sex from the left right this is why you
have no means no rules in places like
California on campus where you're
basically supposed to have a signed
checklist before every aspect of sex
like every single can I touch your arm
now can I touch your leg now you're
supposed to actually ask before every
single one of these things which has
never happened in the history of sex the
left hit though because the left refused
to dry and clear lines now they have to
fall back on drawing new lines that are
both unclear and over restrictive now
this is not to defend Glen thrush I
think Glen thrushes obviously sounds
like a scuzzbag but it is to show that
the vagary that the left has created
with regard to the sexual revolution has
not been of benefit to women in many
cases it's actually been of damage to
women and this is why I think because
these lines are not clear I think it's
it's so obvious that men are will men
use the bad men will use the the
vagueness of the lines in order to cross
the lines that no one would want them to
cross bad men will use the fact that
things are vague to suggest well you
know maybe it wasn't like totally
consensual it was kind of consensual
wasn't it
right so in that category Falls for
example Russell Simmons and Brett Ratner
according to women and carry Klaus and
colleague carry Klaus and colleague E is
a model and she told the LA Times in a
Sunday report that she met Russell
Simmons and Brett and Brett Ratner at a
casting call in 1991 when she was 17 she
said they brought her over to Simmons
his house to show her a music
they were working on and that's when the
music mogul started to pull off her
clothes I looked over at Brennan said
help me and I'll never forget the look
on his face she said in that moment the
realization fell on me that they were in
it together
she says that Russell Simmons tried to
have intercourse but she resisted and he
ended up forcing oral sex colleague he
said she tried to take a shower because
she felt disgusting and there Simmons
essentially raped her penetrate her
without permission
she claims have told at least three
people about this incident so these guys
should go to jail right if this is what
happened these guys should go to jail
obviously the question is and what was
in Russell Simmons his mind that he
thought that this was okay so Radner and
Simmons say quote everything that
occurred between Kari and me was
consensual right everything that was
consensual
so there's two ways of reading that one
is that they just have completely
different accounts of the situation in
one of them is lying and the other is
that there is this weird gray area that
now exists with regard to consent where
if a guy pushes a girl hard enough and
then she says yes for a moment she feels
like she's been violated because she has
been violated from her point of view but
the guy doesn't feel like he's been
violated because he's achieved the
cherish yes even by using all sorts of
exploitative methods now again if you
had some clear lines about sexual
activity all of this would become
obsolete you don't have to do any of
this
you'd say Russell Simmons invited a 17
year old girl to his house and then had
sex with her or tried to force her into
sex
that's gross not just because of the
consent issue but because Russell
Simmons much older guy there's a the
this is this is just you know deep down
that this is immoral activity I don't
know if it is Russell Simmons married
you might be I don't know the answer to
that but in any case clear lines the
left likes to say that clear lines are
over broad but the problem is that the
left left draws its own lines that are
over broad to whenever it comes to lines
regarding sexual behavior you're going
to catch up some people who are really
not supposed to be in that category the
question is whether there can be any
clear conviction that something is wrong
or not we on the right you know
traditional more out of moralist we have
a pretty idea of what's right what's
wrong when it comes to sexual activity
the left has no such ideas this leads to
a fair bit of confusion and I know that
a bunch of people on the left will
listen to the show and they're saying
well my value is consent the point I'm
making is that when it comes to sexual
activity there's a lot of vagueness
regarding consent there is they just
said let's be completely honest about
this okay the the notion that when
people have sex and they I'm not saying
normatively normatively would be
if they're a completely if there is
complete if there's complete
transparency with regard to consent but
in the real world of sexual
relationships there is not always this
clear consent relationship there just
isn't I mean if you how many times do
you see movies where a guy will be
badgering a woman and she's saying no no
no no no and it turns into yes right
there this is it that's not an excuse
for the guy to keep pushing it isn't
that's not what I'm saying the point
that I'm making is we have a culture
that constantly says that women want it
I mean it's the entire music culture
with a movie culture that says that
women want it we have an entire culture
of film that says that half the time
when women say no what they really mean
is yes and we have an entire feminist
movement that spent 40 years trying to
convince women there was just as
libidinous as men and that consent can
be had under any circumstances there's a
lot of murky area here and now the left
is trying to claim that it's black and
white well I want it to be black and
white I have rules I want to know what
the left's specific rules are and I want
to know what their turned their their
specific definition of consent looks
like so we can all apply and we can
determine whether it is correct or not
by the way I'm on the side of all of
these women by the way who say that they
were that they did not consent to these
relationships because again I'm the
prude right I'm the prude I think it's
wrong for guys to ram their tongues down
woman's throat I think it's wrong for
Glen thrush to go drinking with women
and then make out with them without
their permission even if the woman says
that she's totally into it for the first
five minutes and then she says no I
think it's wrong for him to have
initiated this stuff
okay so then I'm pretty strict on this
stuff and it's amazing to see the
feminists join me on this side of the
aisle okay so with all of that said I
want to I want to get to the Trump
category five tweets storm in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Zeile so if you
are in need of massage if you have
racked up your back or you're just
stressed at work and you want to feel
like a wealthy person without actually
having be well think that's what Zeile
is for Zeile is fantastic they bring the
masseuse to your house they are all
licensed masseuses they bring the the
table they bring the massage oils they
bring the candles they bring the whole
deal right anything that they want they
bring to you and then they turn your
house into a spa essentially I've gotten
it for my wife I've got it for another
in-law I've gotten it for my sister I've
gotten it fried parents Zeile is a
fantastic app and unlike the spa where
you have to make a reservation hours
in advance zeal is pretty much immediate
right you can get an in-home massage
same-day it's the perfect solution for
anyone who wants a high quality massage
in the convenience of their own home it
is just awesome to help you get started
our listeners can get twenty five
dollars off their first massage by using
the promo code Bennett at checkout and
it gets better by the way if you sign up
for zeals massage membership and get 20%
off all your massages plus a free
massage table and sheet set that's a
three hundred eighty dollar value yours
for free there's no initiation fee to
join the membership just a great
additional savings on top of the $25
discount you're gonna get when you use
promo code Ben go to zeal spells EEE
Elcom or unseals iPhone or Android app
and then make sure to click add promo
code at checkout to use my code ben and
get $25 off your first in-home on-demand
massage again use promo code Ben get 25
bucks off your first in-home on-demand
massage by the way just a quick note
about the sexual consent issue and the
vagary on the left you're still seeing
this vagrant left cuz one of the
fascinating things you see some people
on the Left saying that Bill Clinton
should have resigned in 1998 now but the
excuse they used for why she should have
resigned varies so some of them say it's
cuz Juanita Broderick because of the
rape allegation true a few of them say
it's cuz of Lewinsky but a bun on the
Left say the Lewinsky was totally
consensual
it was totally consensual he was
pressuring her into the sex she was 18
he was 45 he was married and it
my rules are very clear that's the nice
thing about my rules they're super clear
and they protect women okay they work on
behalf of women if a woman wants to
consent under my rules she can consent
but she has to be extraordinarily clear
about it
right and that clarity sometimes comes
in the form of you know like a wedding
ring like an actual commitment so I
think these are these are useful things
to keep in mind when you formulate a
rule you should try to create a rule
that it's obvious when the rule is
broken and when it's not I think the
left has failed here okay so now I want
to introduce something new so we've had
good Trump bad from for well over a year
on this program a year and a half on
this program but now we have to
introduce something new and that is you
know sometimes Trump says things and
they are just so magnificent they are
just so rhetorically brilliant that we
need a new category it's not really good
or bad it's eloquent Trump and so we
know introduced to you eloquent Trump
[Music]
yes eloquent Trump so on this date
yesterday yesterday on this date in 1863
Abraham Lincoln gave a very famous
speech he gave a speech that we all know
as the Gettysburg Address this took
place on this date this specific date
now November 19th 1863 so yesterday and
in it he declared that we as a union
we're going to have to stand together
and that the better angels and that the
better in nature angels of our nature
were going to bring the country together
and that we cannot we have to not
sacrifice we have to prove these people
should not have sacrificed their lives
in vain that has been matched only by
Donald Trump Donald Trump says he can be
the most presidential president outside
of Abraham Lincoln and I think he proved
that yesterday when he tweeted this
about Lavar ball so remember levar Brawl
levar balls son la Angelo well I don't
know what that what the obsession is in
the family with laws lovara Angelo and
what and what's the name of the kid
Lorenzo is in any case look the letter L
is big there
levar his son Lee Angelo was arrested in
China for shoplifting and as a recalled
Trump got him out of prison and then
demanded a thank you to which the son
act we asked and I said at the time like
this is kind of babyish that the
president wants to thank you for getting
an American citizen out of prison in
China but in any case you know the son
said thank you well then they asked
levar about it and levar said I'm not
gonna thank President Trump I'm not
gonna thank him because levar is also a
member of higher intelligence he
obviously is a high IQ guy and so what
he said is Trump didn't visit my son in
prison well he got him out so you
probably shouldn't say thank you but
then eloquent trump showed up so
eloquent Trump tweeted yesterday now
that the three basketball players are
out of China and saved from years in
jail levar ba the father of Li Angelo is
unaccepting of what I did for his son
and that shoplifting is no big deal I
should have left them in jail
exclamation point
ah eloquent Trump love this stuff um
no you shouldn't left him in jail just
cuz daddy wasn't grateful to you that's
not the way the
nc works I'm gonna talk about why it's
important in just a second but this is
pretty epic Trump yesterday and you just
wonder was he super bored yesterday
didn't like the football like what was
going on with him yesterday he was back
from his trip and he had a lot to get
off his chest that was not the only
eloquent Trump yesterday and he also
tweeted further about Lavar ball he
tweeted shoplifting is a very big deal
in China as it should be five to ten
years in jail but not to father LaVon
should have gotten his son out during my
next trip to China instead trying to
told them why they were released very
ungrateful exclamation point so should
have left them in jail for a few more
months cuz daddy was mean to trump okay
so one thing here so a lot of people who
are Trump supporters find this stuff
absolutely hilarious it is hilarious but
it's hilarious and also tragic because
again yesterday was the anniversary of
the Gettysburg Address eloquent Trump
mmm-hmm
now though the left obviously goes goes
crazy whenever Trump does any of the
sort of stuff so brian Stelter on CNN
says something ridiculous he says this
is race-baiting think about this he's
just recently let the NFL kneeling
controversy starts to subside start to
fade away and now here he is calling out
these players and the families again I
think it's immature at best Fred but
it's really race baiting at worst and
that's gonna be debated that's gonna be
argued about but I want to put that on
the table it sugar looks like race
baiting to a lot of people and by the
way the reason why I think these tweets
are important it's because they are a
serious look okay so it's race baiting
okay first of all I'll show you it's not
race baiting so more eloquent Trump from
was very eloquent yesterday I mean put
on his cravat he grabbed his pipe he
said he fired up the handle and and he
ended up tweeting out this one too it is
what about Jeff Flake so Jeff Flake of
course is the senator from Arizona he's
not running for reelection he said that
he thinks that Trump is basically the
end of the Republican Party and here's
what he tweeted more eloquent Trump
Senator Jeff Flake II he wrote flaky but
he wrote flaky but the why is in
parentheses who is unelectable in the
great state of Arizona
quit race anemic polls was caught
purposely on Mike Mike has spelled mi ke
saying bad things about your favorite
president he'll be a no on tax cuts
because his political career anyway is
quote-unquote toast there's so much that
is glorious about this tweet first of
all the revolutionary use of the scare
quotes it
I don't know why why toast is in square
quotes I don't know why Mike is in scare
quotes I don't know why Mike has spelled
mi ke as opposed to mi see I don't know
why Jeff Flake was on top of some dude
named Mike that's weird I don't know why
Jeff Flake was on top that dude named
Mike saying bad things about my favorite
President Abraham Lincoln I don't know
why Jeff Flake was ripping on Abraham
Lincoln I do love that Trump calls
himself your favorite president he has
the lowest poll numbers of any
presidents in American history
at this point in his presidency
astonishingly grant said favorite
current president that's true Thank You
Austin it's true he's better he is my
favorite current president I don't know
of any other current presidents so there
was Trump on Jeff Flake so lots of
eloquence happening yesterday the reason
that I'm bringing all of this up is
because a lot of people on the right
they go this is why Trump wins he wins
because of these tweets winning winning
epic winning magum Agra underwater
upside down 365 degree 190,000 IQ
underwater upside down on Hungry Hungry
Hippos chess that is what they say
because you're talking about it today
aren't you all right I'm talking about
it today that's true you're right I will
talk about what the presidents of the
United States says the reason why this
is a problem folks is for two reasons
one and this is all coming from a
conservative point of view one it's not
great for the country when the
presidents of the United States is
threatening to leave American citizens
overseas in Chinese custody because
daddy was mean to him that's not a great
thing if Obama did that we'd all go nuts
and rightly so
number two Donald Trump is trying to
make the last-ditch push for a tax cut
right now for serious tax cut
legislation before Thanksgiving or
before Christmas one of the votes he's
going to need is the vote of Senator
Jeff Flake and now he is saying that
Jeff Flake is gonna vote against the tax
cuts giving him full ability to vote
against the tax cuts like this if you
want good legislation to pass you know
what help if the President of the United
States weren't Doug from up weren't the
dog from up chasing every single
squirrel his closing argument on health
care reform if you recall was that Jeff
Sessions was a poopyhead
his closing argument on the second round
of health care reform is that the NFL
player should stop kneeling and now his
closing argument on tax reform is that
he should have left a basketball player
in China under custody and that a
particular Senate
should should be he'll drip on a
particular senator and tell him to vote
no on tax cuts because he's mean to him
like I just don't like why why and that
wasn't it
then he went after Marshawn Lynch day so
Marshawn Lynch is fully fledged adult I
mean Marshawn Lynch the running back for
the Oakland Raiders he used to play for
the Seattle Seahawks I used to do a show
up in Seattle and so he followed
Marshawn Lynch closely Marshawn Lynch is
one of the stupider members of the human
race he's a very very dumb individual
and Marshawn Lynch I mean he's been
famous for this for a long time and
before anybody says that this is
something racial I said like I say that
people are dumb cross racially all the
time are Sean Lynch is just objectively
speaking to them them and Marshawn Lynch
yesterday sat during the United States
national anthem and then stood for the
Mexican national anthem which makes no
sense at all okay whatever you say about
the American national anthem Mexico is a
garbage garbage government I mean the
government there has been a disaster for
years and years and years and years I
mean that the death rate in Mexico City
is higher than in any other
industrialized city in the world I mean
it's it's astonishing but he's standing
for the Mexican national anthem for some
odd reason
today's a genius so a Trump feels the
need to tweet about that right so here's
Trump tweeting about that
so Trump tweeted about Marshawn Lynch
says Marshawn Lynch of the NFL's Oakland
Raiders stands for the Mexican anthem
and sits down to boos for our national
anthem great disrespect next time NFL
should suspend him for remainder of
season attendance and ratings way down
Thank You president Trump like I know
that this is a fight you want to keep
fighting because you think it's a
political winner for you the reason that
I'm upset about this is not just because
it's time to make a final legislative
push it's because he has 43 million
Twitter followers 43 million he's the
President of the United States he has
the ability to gather to gather the
media flies like a lamp remains an
amazing thing and when he uses his
Twitter for good then that is a
wonderful thing I will show you him
using his Twitter for good so yesterday
there's a Border Patrol agent who's
murdered in an attack on the border on
this according to NBC DFW they said
authorities are searching texts is Big
Bend area for potential suspects and
witnesses after US Customs and Border
Protection agents fatally injured
responding to activity their Border
Patrol officials said the agents were on
patrol in Cole Burson County in the Big
Bend sector of the Texas border a
general Hugo Martinez died Sunday
as a result of injuries he and his
partner sustained after responding to
activity while on patrol on interstate
10 near Van Horn according to a
statement from border patrol it wasn't
immediately clear when the incident
occurred
okay so here's what Trump tweeted about
this and this is good he tweeted Border
Patrol officer killed at southern border
another badly hurt we will seek out and
bring to justice those responsible we
will and must build the wall imagine if
all of his tweets were on the news
imagine if all of his tweets were
directed it you know policy and
legislation and he can still say
inflammatory things an inflammatory
thing to say he can still say that and I
will cheer that because he is correct
one of the reasons that you need a
physical barrier in some of these areas
is to prevent the drug cartels from
crossing over and hurting Border Patrol
agents or illegal immigrants from doing
the same it's important to have methods
of Defense it tweeted again on this
right he tweeted as well with regard to
the Border Patrol agents that this is a
clip eight actually so he tweeted on
policy also yesterday not just on the
Border Patrol Republican senators are
working very hard to get tax cuts and
tax reform approved hopefully it will
not be long and they do not want to
disappoint the American public okay
imagine if he only tweeted about tax
reform and the wall would that be better
than saying Lavar ball son should remain
in jail and China yes would be better
than alienating a sitting member of the
United States Senate whose vote you're
gonna need on both the wall and the tax
reform yes yes it would and yet that is
not what President Trump was doing
yesterday it's just it's foolish it's
foolish so you know so much for for
eloquent Trump although I will say I do
love the the tweets give me something to
talk about it's so funny I saw some
magnifying yeah Dinesh D'Souza who I'm
friends with her then Dinesh said
something like you know the media wants
Trump to stop tweeting they want from to
stop tweeting if he's so ineffective why
do they wanted to stop tweeting the
media don't want Trump to stop tweeting
are you crazy
what do you think it's raising MSNBC's
in CNN's ratings if from starts tweeting
stops tweeting though I should have to
treat him like a normal president that's
the scariest thing in the world for them
they want to treat him the way that
they're treating him I want him to stop
tweeting because I don't think that it's
useful to his agenda okay so before I go
any further I'm gonna talk about Roy
Moore and the latest fallout from that
and Al Franken another allegation
against Al Franken coming out plus I
want to talk about Charles Manson so a
lot to get to but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at bird
school
so if you are looking at the economy and
you're figuring that the stock market
might be somewhat inflated you're
looking at tax reform you're doubtful
that it's gonna pass or you just know
that every eight to ten years in this
country there's some sort of recession
then you probably want to hedge some of
your bets with some precious metals
everyone should have part of their
portfolio in precious metals Birch gold
group has a long-standing track record
of continued success with thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau
right now when you contact my friends
over at Birch gold group you can request
a free information kit on physical
precious metals they have a
comprehensive 16 page kit revealing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds if you want
and into a precious metals IRA I always
say ask all of your questions make sure
that you feel comfortable with investing
in precious metals and then once you do
talk to my friends over at Birch gold
get your no cost no obligation kit
birchgold.com / pen pens birchgold.com /
band the / pen lets them know that we
sent you as well okay so over the
weekend the Democrats basically made
clear that they're not gonna get rid of
Minnesota senator Al Franken that's
despite allegations that Al Franken
grabbed the boobs of a sleeping woman
Leon Sweden who's a talk show host out
in Los Angeles they said we're not gonna
don't worry we're not gonna get rid we
would never get rid of Al Franken Al
Franken will apologize and he'll he'll
go home and reflect yeah I'm sure I'm
sure well now a second woman has come
out and alleged that Al Franken is doing
some booty grabbing so here is a woman
so a woman has said this is corny CNN
that Al Franken inappropriately touched
her in 2010 telling CNN he grabbed her
buttocks while taking a photo at the
Minnesota State Fair you know what I
gotta tell you I get the feeling it's
really fascinating I do get the feeling
that there is a generation gap with
regard to behavior of men I sort of get
this feeling that there are a lot of men
over the age of 60 who have grabbed a
woman's ass without permission and that
there are fewer men under the age of 40
who have grabbed a woman's ass
deprivation maybe I'm getting this
completely wrong but if I'm not that
would explain a few things as far as our
politicians and as far as some of our
producers from the idea that Al Franken
I just goes to the Minnesota State Fair
and grabs this lady's but apparently her
name is Lindsey men's she's 33 she now
lives in Frisco Texas so back when this
happened she was 26 she says she wanted
to share an uncomfortable interaction
that helped her whew they left her
feeling gross according to Men's she
attended the Minnesota State Fair with
her
and father in the summer of 2010 almost
two years after Franken was elected to
the Senate
her father's small business was
sponsoring a local radio booth she spent
the day meeting various elected
officials political candidates and
celebrities and taking photos with them
as they stopped by the booth when
Franken walked in men's and her husband
who also spoke with CNN said they
recognized him right away
men said she had a brief and cordial
exchange with the senator then as her
husband held up her phone and got ready
to snap a photo of the two of them
Franken pulled me in really close like
awkward close and as my husband took
Matt took the picture he put his hand
full-fledged on my rear men said it was
tightly wrapped around my butt cheek it
wasn't around my waist he wasn't around
my hip her side it was definitely on my
butt she said last two three or four
second she was like oh my god what is
happening her husband said he kind of
reached around her and pulled her into
him he pulled her in and pushed his head
against her head it was over pretty
quick and you can see the picture in the
picture of her head is right next to her
head apparently she turned to her
husband said he totally grabbed my butt
and then she posted on Facebook that
same day that the senator groped her you
can't see the lower half of their body
in these photos
she said her sister said sorry but you
two aren't Bibles width apart and and
men's then responded due to Al Franken
totally molested me creeper that is that
that exchange is available on Facebook I
only laughed because the lady's funny
apparently she says that she is not
she's not painting her story in the same
light as Leslie tweed ins she says that
she won't she won't say something if
someone sees that I said something maybe
would give them the courage to say
something too Franken has not has not
made any other statement he said he
respects women and doesn't respect men
who don't okay I take pictures with
literally thousands of people I mean
there are thousands of students
including many young college women with
whom I take pictures I can say with full
confidence never at any point
have I ever grasped the ass of a woman
with whom I am taking a picture never
ever ever ever the only but I have ever
touched is that of my wife
okay this idea that you're gonna go and
put like it's so wild like who does this
occur to that you're gonna go take a
picture with somebody and you're just
gonna grab or but like who it's it's
astonishing
it's truly astonishing so I guess this
is this is really common
apparently it's common at work among
even among men I think something like
40% of women's that have been sexually
harassed at work
no it's it's some really high number and
an among men they say 25% say they've
been sexually harassed it works so
people are garbage I think that the
bottom line here is that what's funny
going back to these sort of traditional
sexual mores for just a second
the what traditional conservatives the
reason we draw very strict lines is
because we think that man is inherently
capable of sin the man is not good and
not bad either but he's very capable of
sin and particularly in sexual matters
he's capable of sin and that's why we
draw all these lines around men it's one
of the reasons why we have all of these
rules the lefthand all those rules were
stupid got rid of all the rules and then
they're surprised when the fallout is
bad for women look at the Democrats here
it's pretty astonishing so I want to
show you the hypocrisy the Democrats oh
joy Reid over at MSNBC she says that she
is very disturbed by the fact that many
people are still supporting Roy Moore
the Senate Alabama Republican candidate
who's been credibly accused of child
molestation or at least of a feeble
filio which is the malla station of
girls who have hit puberty but who are
still little girls you know
fourteen-year-old girls Joey Reid says
that she finds the fact that people
still support more disturbing we're
talking about something of such a
different degree you know you talked
about all of the past scandals we talked
about the Monica Lewinsky situation
which was a you know in a clearly
improper relationship we're talking
about children we're talking about
multiple allegations of the abuse of
children and the fact that it's even a
question I think speaks to the position
that the Republican Party finds it's in
morally this should not be a question
and the fact that people are struggling
with whether or not they should continue
to support Roy Moore for reasons of
party power and tribe is incredibly
disturbing okay so I actually agree on a
basic level with joy read the problem is
that her Democratic Party colleagues
don't agree with her own Al Franken so
here's Bernie Sanders desperately
spending away from answering whether if
Al Franken should resign over what is
now obviously clear conduct do you think
that Al Franken should resign I think
that's a decision for Al Franken and the
people of the state of Minnesota my
understanding is that al is a very
popular senator people in Minnesota
think that he is doing a good job and
his political future will rest with the
people of Minnesota
okay so thank you Bernie Sanders for
demonstrating that this stuff is
political all the way around and if
people are drawing lines for political
reasons to include Donald Trump Roy
Moore but not to include Al Franken that
just demonstrates the lines never had
any any sort of reality in the first
place I have condemned you know when
there are allegations against Trump I
condemn Trump with a credible allegation
against Trump I condemn Trump's behavior
when there is tape of Trump talking
about the stuff I can have Trump when it
was Clinton I can have Clinton when it's
pretty more I condemn more and more when
it's Al Franken I can Al Franken one
thing I don't think you can accuse me of
is inconsistency on these particular
matters because my standard has never
changed but when the standard changes
you do have to ask yourself why and the
obvious answer is that Al Franken has a
D by his name okay so I have things I
like things I hate in Federalist Papers
coming up but you're gonna have to
subscribe for that so for $9.99 a month
you can get a subscription to daily
wire.com in doing so you get the rest of
my show live you also get the rest of
Michael Moses show live the rest to me
Andrew Clavin show live on video and
later when you go to watch the show we
cut out the ad so you don't have to
watch the ads even which is pretty
awesome right now if you get the annual
subscription then you get this the very
finest in all beverage vessels the
leftist here is hot or cold tumbler the
Shapiro store is coming as well by the
way when you get a subscription you're
going to be able to get discounts on
items in the Shapiro store today I've
decided that I'm going to try to propose
I would like to create a mug called the
smug mug with my mug on it I think that
that will be a best-seller but you'll
have to get a subscription in order to
get discounts on all that sort of stuff
so for $9.99 a month or annual
subscription ninety-nine dollars a year
plus the annual comes along with the
great tumbler so that's pretty awesome
if you just want to listen later please
subscribe to our channel at YouTube we
have lots of great video that comes out
that's not available if you just
subscribe on iTunes or SoundCloud you
just want to listen later iTunes or
SoundCloud is the place to do it make
sure that you subscribe and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's get some things that
I like and some things that I hate so
things that I like so over the weekend
Netflix released a new movie it's kind
of interesting Netflix is models and now
they're releasing movies on Netflix for
subscribers but also in theaters so you
can actually see this movie in theaters
you know it doesn't demand to be seen in
theaters but it is a it is a good movie
it's an interesting movie the movie is
called mud bound by a guy named dear ISA
I don't know D Ries but I don't know his
work but the movie itself is good there
are some problems that I have with the
film more on the plotting level then on
the then on the portrayal level all the
acting is quite good it's Carey Mulligan
and Jason Clarke and Jason Mitchell and
marriage I obliged who makes an
appearance and she's she's quite good
she actually under plays the part and
Garrett Hedlund is the is kind of the
main character I guess but in any case
the the film is is about these two guys
who go off to World War two one of whom
is a one of whom is a white guy and he
and one of whom is a black guy and they
both live in rural Mississippi and the
white guy comes back and the black guy
comes back and basically the black guy
who's been out fighting for his country
like he is treated exactly as you would
imagine in 1946 Mississippi and it's a
really graphic film it's very difficult
to watch at times but it does paint a
picture of what life must have been like
for a lot of black folks living in rural
Mississippi in the 1940s and reminds us
what racism really looked like in that
time and place it also is about
readjustment coming back from war it's
about really class a lot of it's about
class because it demonstrates how you
know poor white people we're a lot of
them used race as an excuse to look down
on black people who are really of their
same class and there are a lot of things
about the film that are really
fascinating there are a couple of
problems that I have with film here's a
quick spoiler alert there is a
relationship that is engaged in between
the Garrett Hedlund character and the
Carey Mulligan character that I think is
utterly unnecessary naturally undercuts
the plot a little bit I think that it
actually does a disservice to some of
the characters in the movie but a lot of
the movie is quite good you can check it
out here's a little bit the preview
violence is part and parcel of finchy
life I learned how to stitch up a
bleeding wound load and fire a shotgun
my hands did these things but I was
never easy in my mind I held his
heartbeat in my head all the time he was
gone I only pray for him when I was a
liberator people lined up in the streets
waiting for us sometimes I actually miss
it yeah me too
you always talk about cutting out all
their parts the only way to get out from
under there
don't watch you welcome it I won't be
working for them
happy for us
to fight for my country to come back
fine it changed a bit I don't know what
they let you do over there but you and
Mississippi now you use the back door
so what's good about this film is what
it looks like from the film is that you
know all the white people are bad and
all the black people are good and that's
not the case in the film okay we can
stop the preview that's it that's that's
that's not the story the film the story
the film is that there are some that it
takes good white people to stand up to
bad white people and that there are a
lot of black people who are attempting
with honor to live their lives in a
horrifying place so I think the film is
definitely worth watching okay so other
things that alike so Charles Manson's
dad's that's good Charles Manson should
have died you know 40 years ago he was
on death row and then California
suspended the death penalty there's a
Supreme Court decision nationally that's
his spent or at the California Supreme
Court level that support that suspended
the death penalty and everybody who's on
death row at the time had their sentence
commuted to life in prison and instead
instead Charlie Manson ended up living
out his life and dying at age 83 which
is just horrifying considering the
Charlie Manson Charles Manson was a was
just the worst human being ever I mean
this is a guy who's responsible for
dozens of murders he was responsible for
the murder of Sharon Tate then the wife
of Roman Polanski she was 26 years old
she was eight and a half months pregnant
she's about to give birth and he sends
his cult members into her compound and
and murdered her murdered the baby just
an absolute piece of human debris Mille
talked about whether he was insane or
not and he was sane enough to in and
sociopathic enough to lead a cult
movement and what wasn't what's
important to remember is that there were
people on the left and this is not
exaggerating a case there were
legitimately people on the Left who were
praising Charles Manson like this is
Charles Manson was a was was praised by
some members of the radical left
including Bernardine Dohrn so you
remember Bernardine Dohrn is the wife of
Bill Ayers Bill Ayers of course was
weatherman Underground's hos Bernardine
Dohrn well after Charles Manson was he
has people murder people and right pig
on the walls
Bernadine Dohrn praised him Bernadine
Dohrn actually said that she did that
she dug it right so that it's it's
really quite horrifying there there were
a few
people on the Marxist Left who suggested
this was just a form of class warfare
and praised all of it she what here's
what Bernardin publicly announced in
1969 Bernardin to understand offing
those rich pigs with their own forks and
knives and then eating a meal in the
same room far out the Weathermen dig
Charlie Manson and this guy was a cult
figure not just on you know among his
cult members but to certain extreme
members of the left now he'll be burning
in hell
you know the Judaism doesn't believe in
the idea of an eternal hell but if it
does exist he will certainly be burning
there as well he should evil evil human
being garbage Hoonah me okay other
things that I like aside from Charles
Manson's death so I have to admit that
this is really really funny so Lena
Dunham who's made a career out of
pretending to be a feminist while
undermining found while undermining
women everywhere I mean really by doing
things like leveling false rape
allegations at a guy who she names and
then has to retract the name and
abandoning animals and I mean she's not
bad personally and done them all the way
around saying and took bragging in her
memoir about pleasuring herself next to
her younger sister in bed I mean just
really a gross person in any case she
was now smacked down by Zinzi Clemens in
Z Clemens a leftist who happens to be
black she said his time for women of
color black women in particular to
divest from Lena Dunham
a writer for Lena Dunham and Jenny
Connors Lenny letter has accused the
former of hipster racism she says it's
time for women of color to divest from
Lena Dunham he's back in college had
avoided those people like the plague
because of their well known racism I'd
call their straight hipster racism which
typically uses sarcasm as a cover and in
the end it looks a lot like gas lighting
it's just a joke why are you
overreacting she says the one female in
Lena's circles was quote known to use
the n-word in conversation in order to
be provocative and if she was ever
called in it she would say it's just a
joke I was often in the same room with
her but I never spoke to her only
watched her from afar and anxiety and
horror she said she decided to leave
Lenny letter after Dunham expressed her
support for the gear the girls writer
Marie Miller who was accused of sexual
assault by actress Aurora Perrineau
Clemens wrote that one of my best
friends was victimized in almost the
exact same way by someone and Lenny at
Leena's circle it was never addressed he
continues to move in those circles and
has a powerful job so pretty pretty
hilarious that the left is now eating
itself and no one could deserve it more
than the execrable lena dunham okay time
for some things I hate already so a
couple of quick things that I hate
number one there are a bunch of people
on the right who passed this stuff
around like it's really glorious there
is a CNN broadcast yesterday from
Alabama and somebody ran up in the
background and started shouting here's
what it looked like the day they are
pretty much endorsing the Democratic
challenger Doug Jones you see this bold
headline here and this is what they say
and part of it their editorial saying
quote do not make your voting decision
based on who it will affect on a
national stage vote based on who it will
affect in your hometown there's only one
candidate left in this race who has
proven worthy of the task representing
Alabama he is Doug Jones it's Roy Moore
fans shouting fake news fake news fake
news this does not do anyone on the
right any favors when we suggest that
this sort of behavior is is useful the
reason that it's not useful is not
because CNN doesn't sometimes push fake
news sometimes they do push fake news
the reason this behavior is not useful
is because you ought to actually focus
in on the fake news that they tell
instead of just labeling things broadly
fake news yeah I still believe in things
like true and false I still believe in
those concepts I think the majority of
Americans do and simply shouting that
everything CNN ever broadcast is fake
news is a lie it is not true okay just
as when the left says everything daily
wire says it's fake news not true you
have to say what we said is wrong and
what what exactly that is and then we
can talk about whether it was fake news
or not okay other things that I hate so
there are certain statements that you
get to make in the United States if
you're not a white person that if you
reverse the races would be utterly out
of bounds there's an MSNBC panelists who
yesterday was talking about threats to
America our name is Jumeirah Burleigh
she's the founder of Gen Y not just
awesome and and here's what she had to
say about threats to America this is
nothing new what is interesting though
is that white men continue to be that
pose the biggest threat to Americans
every single day it's been documented
and verified that they are more likely
to burn down churches more likely to
commit mass murders and mass shootings
and so Jeff Sessions reality and his
assessment on on these people I think is
both lacking in facts and both reality
okay so one the reason
is coming up is because there's an FBI
report on some members of black lives
matter supposedly or at least what they
were calling black identity extremists
people who are sort of people who were
sort of black radicals who were involved
in violence that does exist it happens
and it's something that the FBI has been
focused on and she says the white men
are the greatest threat um white men are
not statistically the greatest threat
when it comes to a murder but the idea
that linkage that the race the racial
linkage is the one that matters can you
imagine if somebody said black men are
the greatest threat to America yeah it's
just insane
black men are the greatest threat to
human beings across the United States
like what in the world but you can say
this about white guys not even
statistically true I mean if we're
talking about murder rate and we're
talking about groups of people who are
disproportionately likely to murderer or
rather disproportionately involved in
murder cases let's put it that way we do
who are a just represent a
disproportionate share of murderers it
is not white people actually but that
does not mean that black people are more
likely to murder as like individuals or
that white people are less likely to
murder as individuals because of race
that's silly and if the white people
said anything like that they would be
accused of racism but MSNBC panelists
can say the sort of stuff no problem and
everybody just sort of shrugs okay time
for a quick review the Federalist Papers
so every week we go through new
Federalist Papers today happens to be
not one of the most stirring Federalist
Papers this one is Federalist number
four by John Jay again the the
Federalist Papers begins with this
series of papers about why we shouldn't
form separate countries which has some
relevance now that it seems like half
the country wants to form separate
countries but the idea in this
Federalist paper is we can't have a
bunch of different elements of the
United States we can't have a bunch of
different regions that they have their
own foreign policy because foreign
nations will pick one region of the
United States against another so John
Jay writes this he says whatever may be
our situation whether firmly united
under one national government or split
into a number of Confederacy's certain
it is that foreign nations will know and
view it exactly as it is and they will
act toward us accordingly if they see
that our national government is
efficient and well administered our
trade prudently regulated our militia
properly organized and disciplined our
resources and finances discreetly manage
our credit reestablished our people free
contented and United they'll be much
more disposed to cultivate our
friendship our then provoke our
resentment okay so the reason that this
is still important today
is not because we have a bunch of
regions it's because it is true that
when the United States is internally
divided on key issues and we don't even
have the same definition of what freedom
looks like or what vision we have for
the country then our opponents overseas
are going to see that and they're going
to exploit it
this was most obviously true during the
Vietnam War when a huge percentage of
the country was attempting to actively
undermine our presence in the Vietnam
War and Ho Chi Minh knew that full well
and felt like if he held out long enough
we we'd pull out which is exactly what
happened obviously terrorists felt the
same way about the war in Iraq when the
United States is internally divided on
key issues the rest of the world knows
it this is not the case for bad unity
right the dissent is fine but we should
recognize that there is well-motivated
disunity well-motivated dissent and then
there's just a cent for the sake of
political gain descend for the sake of
political gain ends up demonstrating to
our foreign adversaries that we can be
had and right now I'm seeing a lot of
that politically and it's very
disturbing ok we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest news on
this Thanksgiving week i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]